shocking scares cannibal slushings Jared
Leto sometimes a horror movie goes too
far and that's when audiences decide
they've had quite enough
if you are familiar with the work of
David Cronenberg it probably shouldn't
surprise you to learn that audiences
walked out of his latest film a director
known for a pulsive body horror films
such as scanners and the Fly
cronenberg's 2022 sci-fi movie Crimes of
the future follows human beings who
volunteers have their bodies mutilated
for the sake of performance art never
want to spare the audience some truly
nauseating visuals Cronenberg was
certainly prepared for possible walkouts
ahead of its release ahead of the film
screening at the Cannes Film Festival
that year he told deadline I'm sure that
we will have walkouts within the first
five minutes of the movie I'm sure of
that some people who have seen the film
have said that they think the last 20
minutes will be very hard on people and
that there'll be a lot of workouts some
guys said that he almost had a panic
attack while aware of his own reputation
and the typical audience reaction to his
films the director seemed perfectly
happy for viewers to leave before the
credits rolled and that's a good thing
too because that's exactly what happened
following the film's initial press
screenings journalist Kyle Buchanan
tweeted that more than a dozen people
had Departed the film Midway through but
if you think that means critics didn't
like it think again because the film
also received a reported six-minute
Standing Ovation from its can audience
sometimes a lesser known horror movie
can shock audiences into leaving the
theater too take the British Indie flick
men for example which comes from ex
machina director Alex Garland the movie
revolves around Harper Marlow a young
Widow who takes some time to herself in
a remote Village after the death of her
husband only to be terrorized by the
strange people who live there it's The
Surreal journey into the bazaar a story
full of unusual and disturbing imagery
that's meant to shock confound and
ultimately convey a message about toxic
masculinity unfortunately the movie was
hated by some audiences and proved a
little too unsettling for others earning
it some pretty harsh user reviews online
some found men so disturbing that they
walked out on Twitter and Tick Tock
users describe the scene in theaters
with a number of users saying they'd
walked out themselves after feeling too
traumatized
I can fully imagine it must be dreadful
for you
still while men is clearly not a movie
made for the squeamish it received
fairly solid reviews from critics upon
its release
director Lars von Trier is known for his
deeply provocative films such as his
two-part erotic Thriller nymphomaniac or
the supernatural psychosexual nightmare
Antichrist but while some audiences may
have been horrified by those works it
was his 2018 slasher the house that Jack
built that really drove them to the exit
the house that Jack built is an esoteric
exploration of the psyche of a serial
killer who Bears his soul to the ancient
Roman poet Virgil or being led through
Dante's version of Hell on its release a
film garnered positive reviews for its
nuanced performances and impressive
Direction but it also met with plenty of
condemnation from critics who decrytus
graphic violence which also caused many
to leave the film before it finished
speaking about the film's can debut
varieties Ramin satuda wrote I've never
seen anything like this at a film
festival more than 100 people have
walked out of larsvan's Trias the house
at Jack Bells which depicts a mutilation
of women and children it was quite the
return for canva volunteer who had
previously been banned from the festival
for comments he made regarding Adolf
Hitler in response to the walkouts Von
Tria stirred the pot further claiming he
was happy that it had upset audiences
enough to leave
Darren Aronofsky is known for his
intimate intense character studies which
include movies such as the whale and
Black Swan in 2017 however Aronofsky
wrote and directed mother a
psychological horror movie that carries
a number of religious and environmental
themes the movie stars Jennifer Lawrence
as a young married woman whose husband
and author labors under the pressure of
rising is next great work but after a
stranger is reluctantly welcomed into
their home the man's wife and two adult
sons follow as the woman protests a new
family's escalating disruptions she
becomes ever more confused by her
husband's insistence on letting the
intruding family into their home
not nearly as straightforward a film as
it sounds mother is full of symbolism
philosophy and allegory Burton likes
some horror movies this film didn't
prompt people to depart by terrifying
them instead it annoyed them maybe the
deeper meaning of the story was lost on
these viewers or maybe the less than
literal nature of the story proved
frustrating either way use it online
from Reddit to Twitter described leaving
the theater before it was over today
mother stands out living proof that
people don't always walk out of a horror
movie because it's scary
if there's a modern day equivalent to
The Exorcist the horror movie so
traumatizing that it's instantly ranked
among the most terrifying movies ever
made it's got to be hereditary written
and directed by Harry Astor hereditary
begins with Annie Graham and her family
grieving over the death of her mother
Burton the wake of their loss an even
more grisly death occurs enter attempts
to commune with the lost loved one only
reveal mob secrets about the family's
long lineage quickly gaining notoriety
for its stunning twists and turns
hereditary became one of the most talked
about horror films in recent memory and
earned rave reviews from critics though
the film plays for the fears of parents
most of all it terrified viewers of all
ages one particularly gruesome scene
left audiences in enough shock that some
viewers walked right out we won't spoil
anything for you but suffice to say it's
not a particularly nice moment turns out
Satan's got nothing on ariesa over the
years and night shyamalanas become
famous for directing movies with
compelling Mysteries capped off by
jaw-dropping twists after a string of
hits in the 90s and 2000s some Alum
released 2008's The Happening a movie
that was heavily marketed around some
great secret trailers for the movie
teased of post-apocalyptic event with
cryptic Clues are suggested an unknown
attack of some sort was killing Millions
across United States affecting all of
the biggest cities ultimately the
cataclysm turns out to be a toxin that
causes victims to take their own lives
and the big twist is that it's not a
terrorist attack or a man-made virus but
a naturally occurring phenomenon a silly
enough premise on its own the film is
also lombasted for its stilted
performances cringe-inducing dialogue
and sloppy script
just going to talk in a very positive
manner
we're just here to use the bathroom
it's apparently so bad in fact that the
happening regularly shows up on lists of
movies that people say they walked out
of one online commenter said that the
only thing memorable about the film was
that they took the unusual step of
leaving they wrote my dad and I still
talk about walking out of that theater
to this day so it left more of an impact
on me than several other films in the
mid to late 90s the internet was an
emerging new medium and so a number of
sci-fi Thrillers tried to capitalize on
the mystery of the World Wide Web
I want to get online I need a computer
horror movies are a little late to the
party however one of the first attempts
to scare audiences of what might look on
the internet was a 2002 slasher fear.com
the movie follows an NYPD detective who
looks into a string of murders leading
him to a website that may be killing
those who log on that might sound like a
fresh take on a ghostly Slasher in
theory in practice however fear.com
didn't score many points for originality
with critics such as Cynthia Fuchs of
Pop matters feeling it was just an
updated version of video drone rip off
or not though what it definitely lacked
was a good script and satisfying scarce
all in all fear.com wound up being one
of the worst horror movies of the decade
and proved terrible enough to spark some
workouts from moviegoers over on Reddit
a user replying to a topic about movies
that walked out on cited fear.com
writing it was the only time I didn't
care that I paid to watch a movie it was
just so awful
there wants a ton of superhero horror
movies out there but morbius took a bite
to the sub-genre in 2022 based on a
lesser known Marvel character first
introduced in the pages of The Amazing
Spider-Man morbius was supposed to add
to Sony's emerging shared Universe based
on characters from the Spider-Man
franchise the movie star Jared Leto as
Dr Michael morbius a scientist who
attempts to self-treat the debilitating
blood disorder with an experimental
serum that turns him into a vampiric
monster forced to consume human blood to
stay alive Mobius blurs a line between
good and evil in a battle with Milo
another and living vampire like himself
I'm starting to get hungry
you don't want to see me
see me Mobius enjoyed some major hype
before his release and quickly became
even more famous for being absolutely
terrible inspiring a full-blown meme
craze morbius induced enough groans at
fans went online to talk about or that
abandoned the movie Midway through with
one fan declaring on Reddit it was
morbin time to get the out of that
theater in his review of the film nerbot
reviewer Derek Murray called it a barely
passable attempt at filmmaking and
lamented that he had not left the
theater himself
the 2022 film the outward says was
praised for bringing something new to
the found footage sub-genre the story
follows four friends who embark on a
camping trip in the Mojave Desert that
goes disastrously wrong a film that may
be a better work of Visual Arts than it
is a horror movie in the strictest sense
it was lauded by critics and attracted
particular attention for its mesmerizing
visuals and stunning use of sound on the
other end of the spectrum audiences
weren't quite as keen on the film with
many theater patrons less than thrilled
about its gratuitous Gore and that use
of sound well for many actually induce
dizziness and nausea on Twitter one user
described their experience writing the
sounds made me so uncomfortably dizzy
that I had to leave the theater to vomit
this never happened to me before it's
more disturbing than scary if that makes
any sense according to another moviegoer
the film proves so unsettling that it
set off their apple watch's heart rate
monitor they wrote the outwaters is one
of the most deranged nightmares I've
chosen to sit through in a while I quite
literally was trembling in multiple
Parts the sound is absolutely hellish
it should come as no surprise that Eli
Roth The Man Behind such horror flakes
as hostile and Cabin Fever made a movie
that had audiences scurring away from
their seats the film in question was The
Green Inferno a blood-soaked cannibal
slasher that turned the dial up on the
gore for the sake of Shia's shock value
the film Chronicles the travels of
Justine a woman who travels to the
Amazon and discovers a tribe of
indigenous cannibals Green Inferno is a
No Holds Barred shock Fest assaulting
the audience with the most hideous see
vile imagery the director Can Dream up
it is so horrific in fact that Stephen
King gave his seal of approval calling
it a glorious throwback to the drive-in
movies of my youth bloody gripping hard
to watch but you can't look away the
wild king himself couldn't take his eyes
off the screen some people couldn't even
stay in the theater in online
discussions about movie walkouts Green
Inferno pops up fairly frequently and
it's not always due to the Gore as one
commenter posted Reddit thank you for
making me think this was a good movie
oh